an arrow function has a shorter syntax
than a standard function and does not
bind its own this these function
expressions are best suited for non
method functions so this is the arrow
right here so here are a few examples of
how you can write a an arrow function so
in parentheses you can put parameters
and then you put the arrow function and
in these curly braces you can put the
statements or you can just put an
expression without curly braces and when
you just have this expression without
curly braces it's going to return this
so this next line here is equivalent to
this line if you put the return it's
going to return the value of this
expression but if you don't put the
return it's still gonna return the value
of this expression as long as there's no
curly braces parentheses are optional
when there's only one parameter these
two are equivalent so there's no
parentheses here if you ever have a
function with no parameters it requires
parentheses okay now here's what a arrow
function will actually look like
compared to a normal function so here's
the normal function or you just have
that the name and then function passed
an x and y and then here's the statement
or expression that you're gonna return x
sense y but you could write that as an
arrow function it's gonna be a lot
shorter you would either write it like
this or like this these are equivalent
because you don't necessarily need the
curly braces and you don't need the
return statement either so this would be
the the pretty short way of doing it now
arrow functions work really well with
higher-order functions such as map
filter and reduce that take other
functions as arguments for processing
collections of data so here's an example
so let's say we have this materials
array and here are three ways to do the
same thing we have material links one
materials length two and materials link
three so I'm gonna do materials map
which you pass in a function and here's
passing in a standard function where
we're just going to return material that
length but you could do it like this
here we have the arrow function and
we're gonna do the same thing but then
we can even shorten the arrow function
to put all in one line and you can just
do material arrow materials that went
material
length so that's gonna be a lot cleaner
than doing then doing it like this until
arrow functions every new function to
find its own this value an aryl function
does not create its own this context so
this has its original meaning from the
enclosing context so the following code
is going to work that as expected so we
have this person function and down here
we're going to create a new person so we
have vista age equals zero and then
we're going to do the set interval where
we pass in a function and inside this
function we're going to add one to the
age in a normal function the word this
here is gonna refer to the global object
but here with the arrow function it's
gonna refer to the person object so it's
gonna work as expected it's actually
gonna change the vista age here instead
of the vista age that would be in the
global object another thing you should
know about this is whenever you're going
to return an object you always have to
put the object in parenthesis if you
look at this line right here inside
these curly braces could refer to the
statements that you want the function to
run but it also could refer to an object
so to make it clear you're gonna have to
put the object in parenthesis if you
want to return an object and the final
thing I want to talk to you about for
arrow functions today is that you're not
allowed to have line breaks see how it
could break so next line now if you're
using curly braces that would be okay
but without curly braces you're just
gonna have to put it all on one line
well thanks for watching my name is beau
Carnes don't forget to subscribe and
remember use your code for good